now if you've been watching my channel
this video is probably not for you but
it's for your friends and family that
eat carbohydrates because we know you
are on the ketogenic diet so if you have
friends and family that are not on the
ketogenic diet you can show them this
video but the question is why
do people crave salt after they eat
sweet
or even after they eat some carbohydrate
we're going to talk about why that is
so let's say for example your friend
not you
eat some cake
drink some soda
eats candy cookies
a donut ice cream and then later that
day or night
start craving some salt they need some
chips right they need something salty
why is that because when you start
getting high blood glucose there's too
much sugar in the blood sodium starts
leaking out of your cells because of
what glucose does to the cell it's very
osmotic which i don't want to get into
the details
on the mechanism
but just realize that when you have high
glucose in your blood
you tend to lose sodium in certain
places in the body and you also become
deficient in potassium so you have
hyponatremia which is low sodium and
hypokalemia which is low potassium
now the symptom
of low sodium would be you crave salt
and you can actually develop a headache
or have adrenal stress you can feel more
stress and this is why sometimes when
people
eat more salt they they feel calm they
can actually relax
and their cravings go away their
headaches go away at least for a minute
but what are the cravings for low
potassium
there is none you're not going to crave
a big salad after this event are you
usually not because there's no
cravings when you're low in potassium
even though you should be consuming a
high potassium food like a big salad
people don't
the ratio
of sodium to potassium should be one to
two you should always have twice as much
potassium
so here's a person who eats the carb
then they eat the salt they satisfy this
but they don't satisfy potassium because
when you actually just have more salt
without the potassium you create even
more of a deficiency of potassium if you
look at the ratios and then all sorts of
other things will happen you may get
palpitations you may feel this loud
pounding in the ear inner ear like your
heartbeat is
like that
on the pillow when you're trying to
sleep you're going to have a hard time
sleeping because potassium is a
physiological
tranquilizer it relaxes you potassium
also gives you energy so you may feel
fatigue you may feel out of breath when
you're going up the stairs potassium
also is involved with preventing leg
cramps because it's an electrolyte and
it's needed in the muscles for various
things so for those of you that are on
carbs
you don't want to forget about this
potassium to take that either in a
supplement or an electrolyte or just a
large salad but for those of you that
are regularly watching my videos
you don't have to worry about this whole
thing because you're not eating carbs so
you're not going to develop these issues
right here because you're doing the
healthy version of keto but if you're
not on keto and you want to know how to
do this i put a link down below and i'll
explain exactly how to do the healthy
version of keto and in a minute
fasting so if you're enjoying my content
which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website
where you can upload your success story
so you can help inspire others